es könnte alles so schön sein es gibt
nämlich eine total simple und schlüssige
erklärung für die dunkle materie
demnach existiert die dunkle materie als
solche gar nicht und gibt uns damit auch
nicht mehr das rätsel auf aus was sie
besteht sondern sie besteht aus etwas
was wir bereits gut kennen nämlich
schwarze löcher allerdings gibt es jetzt
eine neue studie die diese hypothese
einen strich durch die rechnung macht
klick zum science fiction täglich
science videos abonniert den kanal dann
verpasst er nichts herzlich willkommen
es wäre so schön simpel was wäre wenn
das ganze universum voller schwarzer
löcher wäre viel mehr als wir zur zeit
vermuten was wäre wenn der
hauptbestandteil des weltalls schwarze
löcher werden dann könnten sie ja die
dunkle materie sein warum ganz einfach
die dunkle materie ist ja mit ihrer
gravitation dafür verantwortlich dass
sich galaxien anders verhalten als sie
würden wenn sie nur aus materie bestehen
würden die sternsysteme am äußeren rand
bewegen sich viel schneller als erwartet
als wenn nur die sichtbare materie
vorhanden wäre aber genau dieses
verhalten müsste nicht die dunkle
materie sondern könnten schwarze löcher
genauso verursachen sie kennen wir schon
und wir wissen sehr genau was sie
verursachen und nämlich genau das und
wenn man sich auf wikipedia in den
ersten satz zur beschreibung der dunkle
materie ansieht dann ist das eine
absolute erleuchtung dunkle materie ist
eine postulierte form von materie die
nicht direkt sichtbar ist aber über die
gravitation wechselwirkt und auf was
trifft genau diese beschreibung zu exakt
auf schwarze löcher
das würde auch erklären warum die
seltsamen teilchen der dunklen materie
nie gefunden wurden alexander kaczynski
vom goddard space flight center der nasa
hat eine studie dazu veröffentlicht
seine these in den ersten sekunden
unseres universums haben sich als erstes
die schwarzen löcher so genannte primor
ideale schwarze löcher gebildet sie
bilden die dunkle materie und haben
überhaupt dafür gesorgt dass die materie
die nicht in sie gestürzt ist sterne
systeme und galaxien bilden konnte sie
waren nämlich eigentlich zu heiß dafür
die schwarzen löcher haben sie durch
ihre gravitation er so komprimiert
die gestirne bilden konnten zitat diese
studie macht sich zum anliegen
verschiedene ideen und beobachtungen
zusammen zu bringen und zu untersuchen
wie gut sie zusammenpassen und sie
passen überraschend gut das sagt pesch
linz gibt zitat wenn das alles korrekt
ist dann sind alle galaxien
eingeschlossen unsere eigenen in eine
gewaltige sphäre von schwarzen löcher
eingebettet von denen jedes rund 30 mal
massereicher ist als die sonne
die größten schwarzen löcher und die
durch das verschmelzen von schwarzen
löchern entstanden sind haben dann
materie um sich gesammelt und so die
galaxien gebildet und die ersten
gravitationswellen schienen auch in
diese richtung zu deuten so große
schwarze löcher galten bis dato als
extrem unwahrscheinlich wenn es also
solche schwarzen löcher gebe könnten sie
die dunkle materie erklären und damit
wäre das seltsame verhalten der galaxien
erklärt man bräuchte keine neuen
elementarteilchen keine neuen oder
modifizierten gesetze der gravitation
alles wäre prima wenn tja wenn es da
nicht eine neue studie gebe und die haut
jetzt alles auseinander
miguel zumal nach peru und oberzell
young ich hoffe ich das richtig
ausgesprochen von der university of
california in berkeley haben nämlich auf
eine etwas ungewöhnliche methode nach
schwarzen löchern gesucht sie haben sich
1300 supernovae des typs 1a vorgenommen
sie entstehen durch die gleichen
astrophysikalischen effekte und haben
deshalb immer die gleiche helligkeit
würde jetzt ein schwarzes loch
vorbeiziehen würde es eine
gravitationslinsen bilden und das
leuchten würde heller aber pustekuchen
in keinem fall konnten sie das
feststellen wenn die dunkle materie aus
schwarzen löchern bestehen würde müsste
das in dem ein oder anderen fall
passieren nur wenn es zu wenige schwarze
löcher gibt und wenn sie damit auch
nicht die dunkle materie erklären dann
würde man das phänomen nicht feststellen
sie sagen schwarzer löcher könnten das
phänomen der dunkle materie so maximal
nur zu 40 prozent erklären
tja schade oder auch nicht vielleicht
ist diese spur ja gar nicht so falsch
vielleicht sind es ja verschiedene
phänomene die zum effekt einer
vermeintlichen dunklen materie führen
wir können gespannt sein was da noch so
alles herauskommen wird wenn er als
erstes neues zur dunklen materie
zu allen anderen dem erfahren wollt dann
endet meine telefonnummer ihr whats app
dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen
anderen vom neuesten video täglich
garantiert und zur begrüßung gibt es
noch ein kleines geschenk einfach hier
draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo
mit der genau glocke vergessen und hier
gehts weiter also darunter dafür auch
draufklicken dunkle materie gefunden
ansonsten bis dahin bleibt dran